here in eastern Pennsylvania is a fire
that has been burning for 53 years to
the day it's going to be burning for
another 250 more it started simply in
1962 with a dump fire on Memorial Day it
happened all the time they usually just
burned themselves out this particular
dump fire spread and it spread to an
open coal vein this fire would start a
slow-motion disaster that would consume
and destroy the town of Centralia over
the next 50 years
so Centralia sits on a huge vein of
anthracite coal and was founded in the
mid-1800s with a specific purpose of
coal mining
today for the first 20 years the fire
went largely unaddressed people didn't
necessarily consider it emergency in
1981 everything changed
Valentine's Day 1981 12 year-old Todd
Dombrowski was playing at his
grandmother's backyard when the earth
opened up below his feet
I see his smoke and I thought I didn't
want hurt my grandmother's veneer
because she's elderly and I was worried
about her so I went over to see if was
the mine fire when I did I just fell
right through luckily his cousin was
right there grabbed him and pulled him
out before he fell what turned out to be
into the hundred and fifty foot hole
that had been created Centralia went
from being an anonymous town with a
little coal fire problem to being a huge
national concern the question was what
were they gonna do about this town that
was on fire it divided the town in half
half the people wanted to stay they
wanted to make it a better place to live
they said it was safe the other half
were basically looking for federal funds
to leave they said we don't want to be
here it got really ugly and finally it
ended in a vote more than half the town
voted to leave and that was the moment
that Centralia truly began unraveling so
in 1984 most of the residents were
bought out and given funds to leave
Centralia in 1992 the town was
officially claimed using eminent domain
in 2002 the postal service officially
revoked the zip code for Centralia and
finally in 2009 the governor of
Pennsylvania began enforcing the eminent
domain trying to make the last few
residents which at this point was down
to 11 leave the town but the residents
that were still here
didn't want to go their argument was
that the coal fire had actually moved it
was headed towards other towns now and
that Centralia air quality was back to
as good as or better than it was before
the coal fire started they were allowed
to stay as a 2013 they were given
permission to live out their lives here
but when the last ten residents of
Centralia died the town officially will
cease to exist
Centralia is certainly the most famous
example of a coal mine fire but it's
it's actually one of 38 active coal mine
fires in the state of Pennsylvania one
of hundreds in the US and if you get
into India or China we're talking about
thousands and thousands of active coal
mine fires and in fact the collective
output of carbon monoxide of coal mine
fires may account for as much as 1% of
global warming
much like chernobyl Centralia has enough
kind of ruin capital it's a go-to I
think as a kind of pop cultural
reference for abandoned disaster you
know this is sort of a town gone wrong
the thing that looks the most like a
ruin is this abandoned Turnpike there's
not much left I mean the buildings are
basically gone it looks like a bunch of
overgrown Lots ah slowly turning back
into forest and one day you know that's
what it'll be it'll be some streets
through a forest and no one will think
twice about what was here once before